the way we're going to enter into this
new idea is to take something that we
learned just now or with the
demonstrated just now which is that we
rate another like this you need X 4 we
read that as and you guys actually said
the phrase quite a few times how do we
read it how do we say that actually are
commutative altogether right
we read that as 2 - how that's what that
thing is called over there
Oh 70 right so step is the power sort of
true to the power of 7 yes yes please
so it's on the board should be new book
so that's great read true with the set
up their attitude power 7 now I'm going
to write you can probably guess I could
finish off these sentences by saying we
read this as 2 to the power of 2 and we
read this as 2 to the power of 3 right
and that's perfectly fine that's
accurate but there's another kind of
shut up 3/4 way of stains remember that
such as love shorter bring ways of doing
things so I'm gonna give this to you in
another way you might have heard of this
read before we read this not just as too
powerful but we also read it as 2
squared could you raise your hand you've
heard that phrase before is it
it's like a heads up that means I still
love you could tell me what you'd read
this has to keep cubes very good okay
now this is a bit of a tricky one I
don't want you to jump in with an answer
straight away but I would love you to
raise your hand if you think you've got
an idea on this one why do we do that
like this pattern works fine and like
patents are nice when they're always the
same
why introduce this funny new way of
saying about a part of it being shorter
what's the meaning anyone want to be
brave here we record and because in
measurement 2x2 is the width and length
okay okay it's the other piece right
good so in case you didn't catch that
right
the idea is about measurement it's about
things it's out shapes that we burn okay
and if I'd like me to draw this
underneath for you I'm a 2 squared what
is 2 squared by the way to the power 2
is what's the actual number it's for
isn't it so we're right through its
where he was or and decide where you've
written there
where'd you draw for me and if you have
another color that'd be nice drop me
elsewhere now if you've got a square
there and if you have a ruler please use
that whether it be a lot better if you
have a square and each of its sides 2
years long so I would call this a square
of side length 2 because the sides have
a link to okay I can draw my square and
divided up there's one and there's one
which gives me two and there's one in
this one which gives me 2 and now you
can see where the 4 comes from right
four is how big this square is it's how
much space it takes up right so you can
even count one two three four there's
two squared right it's a square wait
slightly too so that's where two square
culture are comparable to this we can
write 2 cubed that's 2 times 2 times 2
whatever is that that's a spring
cute equals eight what are we gonna draw
it out instead of square we're gonna
draw up cube right beside it and this is
a bit tricky to draw but what the way I
do it is I start with the same square
that I begin with and we'll try and make
this a 3d drawing like ice cubes and 3d
shapes so it's gonna go bad okay I've
done the best I can
now you can see again this is a cube and
it's a cute upside leg too except it's
got more than two sides it's got a whole
bunch of different size so I'm going to
label them I've got the side I'm going
to go across the top I decided thank -
which is how is and with the yeah yeah
yeah it's the one that's kind of going
into the bore hole right not not across
not up or down but I guess you could say
it's kind of like it back and forth it's
coming out of the water going into the
board and you can see that the eight
comes from can you see right if we can
sit up how much space our cube took up
the first four cube to the front one two
three four are there and then there's
four more what I did right so I guess
and therefore and four gives us the
eight okay all right so now that we've
established that this idea of squaring a
number or cubing a number right this is
the same thing as raising your power now
I need you in this unusual language of
square roots and cube roots culturally
mr. Johnson oh my golly whew yeah
they're wonderful really
class this is 7m7 aids yes very good bye
to you they look engaged you know
they're really shocked we'll just have a
little fun I bet they're really good at
mentoring oh well they just blowing me
away every lesson so depends misty I
think certain singer they continue to go
yeah yeah okay so we know what swearing
is no Cuban is this your roots it kind
of is out here like when you've got a
tree and you've got roots right roots
are where the tree comes from and they
start from the ground and then it goes
up so the idea of square roots and cube
roots is where did this form where did
it come from and the answer is of equal
to what it is eight comfort the answer
is it came from the Jew that's kind of
where it started okay so I'm going to
introduce for you a little bit of new
notation just like putting numbers up
here's some new notation it's a quicker
in strata I'm gonna give you some new
notation as well okay so we talked about
the square root of a number
and it looks like this it's a really
strange looking sign I'm gonna talk
about the square root for because we
know what that is it's a square number
so I would like this unusual symbol here
okay let me draw it really really huge
for you so that you can see it just a
piston look clear it's sort of a it's
look it has a tick it's not up to the
tick and then you add a hat to it okay
so I call this the square root sign then
the number you're interested in you
should kind of check it underneath okay
so you start with the tick half goes
across this is the square root sign now
the square root of four is what side
length has a square that's this big and
you actually already know the answer
right here's my square and the number
came from was two so the square root of
four is two
okay another way you can say it is and
I'll even write this for you what's the
number I have to swear so that I get
that number of me okay that's a really
helpful way of thinking about it yeah
it's exactly like what is the practice
where and two squared will do it right
so this will be helpful if you are right
this question underneath which tells you
want this notation what it kind of
stands for what's the number I'd have to
swear
once you get and in this case I've got
four right but you can ask for the
square root of any number you like you
could also say the square root of 25
what's the number I have to square to
get 25 ready it's fine right what's the
square root of mmm is it tricky right
121 no what's the square root what
number I squared again hundreds of 21
yeah eleven eleven times eleven hundred
twenty-one you can check it on your
tables right so that's what this is
referring to what no no I'm just way to
get there I wonder if you can guess what
I'll write for the next bit right let's
start by writing a sentence the cube
root of a number and what we do is we
borrowed this same root symbol right but
it's a different kind of roots during
out of shape so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna write that symbol again but to
indicate it's not this thing is this
square root right I put up three there
right it's because it comes from this
it's got here right cubed so this is the
cube root of eight for example let's
just open up a gun this means
what's the number I have to cube to get
eight right which of course we just
wrote on the board is against two so
then I would read that has the cube root
of 8 is 2
now keep your syrupy hotter because cube
numbers uh he got right if ice and whoo
the cube root of eight that's nice and
small but the cube root of that's C 343
doesn't come to your mind so quickly
it's seven five waves okay so you might
not know these as quickly it's alright I
just